hello and welcome to agenda from the
plenary it's a busy day two enemies here
in Brussels but next week budget and
Social Affairs take center stage let's
take a look a week within a week well
two days to be exact as the European
parliamentary week kicks off on Tuesday
elected representatives from national
parliaments will join any pieces
workshop on budgets economics and social
issues the special emphasis on how the
EU spends its money and how to get more
people back in jobs president martin
short's parliamentary vice presidents
and new commissioners will all be on
hand to debate and discuss us-led
airstrikes to wrestle swathes of Iraq
and Syria from the control of the
so-called Islamic state have so far not
had the impact intended and at the peace
process in Syria is in tatters 191,000
people have now died in a Syrian civil
war so what is the plan ahead on Monday
the man tasked with Mission Impossible
the UN and Arab League special envoy to
Syria Staffan de Mistura will talk to
the Foreign Affairs Committee also
dropping in to say meeting is straight
after Yan Ellison un deputy sector
general don't forget to watch
does European law protect children in
some cases it doesn't there is no legal
obligation to provide minors with a
lawyer if they're suspected of a crime
time for new safeguards on Thursday the
civil liberties committee will vote on a
new directive to ensure not only legal
aid but that at every stage from the
police station to the court children are
treated properly and finally it's time
for Berta Super Mario and mario monti
comes to the Parliament where you'll be
discussing better EU funding on Thursday
and that's all we have for this agenda
take care and enjoy the week